أنا في مهمة مثل الكثير من قبل من
خلال الأسوار المغلقة ، أقابل أولئك
الذين يبحثون عن كنز مخفي وأزورهم
خلال الأوقات المرغوبة بالطبع
حتى البحث عن الكنوز يتطلب أقنعة
ومطهرًا بالطبع ،
شكرًا لك مرة أخرى جميل
هذا جيد حسنًا الآن دعنا  اذهب
واعثر على بعض الكنوز
جيدًا التي كنت تجربها
منذ عدة سنوات ،
لذا فأين يقع مسرح
الجريمة في كل مكان حولك ، إنه كل شيء من
حولك
منذ قرون مضت القراصنة يجوبون هذه
البحار ويقولون أن القذائف كانت ملعبهم
[موسيقى  ]
يقال إن غنائمهم غير المشروعة موجودة في
كل مكان
وأن جون كروز ويلكنز هو صائد كنز حقيقي حقيقي ، وهو
صائد كنز حقيقي محفور في
الصخر للقياسات
والاتجاه المصمم
لمواصلة بحث والده ريجينالد
الذي بدأ في عام 1949
بعد وفاة ريجينالد في
التقط 1977 John البحث من حيث
توقف والده ،
فلنلقِ نظرة على هذه الخريطة التي نحن
في الواقع في هذا الجزء خارج الخريطة
الآن لأن  تم تمديد مطاردة الطمأنينة
بعد وفاة والدي
ولن تدعني أرى
بعد الآن ،
ليس الكنز الذي يبحث عنه كلاهما ينتمي إلى
قرصان فرنسي
أوليفييه ليفاسور المعروف باسم
la bousse ،
يعتقد الكثيرون أن الصقر أحضر معه
ودفن
هنا ثروة يعتقد أنها تساوي ما لا يقل عن
مليون دولار قاموا بدفنها في
جزر مهجورة وامتدادات من
القارة ستكون غير مأهولة بالسكان ، لذا
أتوا إلى
سيشيل ، كانت سيشيل خارج خطوط الشحن
وهنا كان لديهم الطعام والماء
وكان لديهم صعوبة  الخشب لإصلاح
سفنهم ، تقول الأساطير إن لا بروسي ترك
أدلة على كنزه
مكتوبًا في هذا التشفير الذي كشف عنه فقط
في اللحظة التي سبقت
إعدامه على حبل المشنقة قبل ما يقرب من
ثلاثة
قرون ، وسلم سيدي ثم أخذ
هذه الورقة
وألقى  من الواضح
أنه قد يكون كنزًا لك من
يمكنه فهم
تلك الأوراق
التي جعلها التشفير في النهاية بين يدي جون  والد
الذي يعتقد أنه فك شفرة
[موسيقى]
ماذا لو لم يكن الكنز هنا ، هل يمكنك
التعايش مع هذا الفكر ،
نعم ، لكن من السهل أن يتمتع جون
بكل ثقة المؤمنين الذين يرون
هذا البحث
حتى النهاية حتى مع قيود الحكومة
حول أين وكيف يمكنه الحفر ، هل أنت
مهووس بهذه القصة ، أعني أن والدك كان
وقد ورثت ذلك ، لكن هل أنت
مهووس بهذا
لا ولكني مفتون به ،
أليس كذلك أن كلمة أخرى جلسة الدعامة
القرصان؟  قذف المخطوطات قبل
تنفيذ التشفير ، القرائن المادية
في الصخور لا أعرف ما إذا كان هذا
صحيحًا
أم لا ، لكن كل ذلك يضيف
لونًا رائعًا إلى هذه
المياه الفيروزية المذهلة